election of MP for the Watford
parliamentary constituency
i George Derbyshire returning officer at
the election of the Member of Parliament
for the Watford parliamentary
constituency held on sentence may 2015
do hereby give notice that the number of
votes recorded for each candidate is as
follows Cottrill voice Aidan green party
1332 Harrington Richard the Conservative
Party candidate 24,400 Lincoln Nick UK
Independence Party you get five thousand
four hundred and eighty-one O'Connor
mark Steven trade unionists against
socialists
I'm sorry trade unionists and socialists
against cuts 178 Thornhill Dorothy
Liberal Democrat ten thousand one
hundred and fifty to two main Matt
Labour Party fourteen thousand six
14,000
14600 and six the total number of ballot
papers rejected and not counted was 200
and the total number of votes recorded
represented 67 point four percent sixty
seven point four seven percent of the
registered electors I do but do hereby
declare that the said Richard Harrington
is duly elected member of parliament for
the Watford constituency
you're welcome
thank you ladies and gentlemen ladies
and gentlemen thank you very much ladies
and gentlemen the returning officer as
Jeff the returning officer counts that
the Derbyshire has given me some Volokh
which he says here is your welcome pack
and I would like to say ladies and
gentlemen it's my proud duty to first of
all thank the hartfordshire police for
everything that they put into making
this campaign what it is today
to the returning officer of course and
all of the staff those people here until
actually by our standards is actually
quite an early result at half-past four
in the morning and to everyone who's
been in the polling stations all day I
really AM on behalf of everybody very
very grateful but I would also ladies
and gentlemen I'd like to thank my huge
team of volunteers from the Watford area
for everything that they've done for me
but apart from them I would just like to
say to everybody but it's been my honor
to serve for the last five years and I
hope that I've served my constituents
without asking them what their political
views are without judging people because
elections are one thing the duty and
responsibility of being an MP is quite
something else and it would be
it's my proud honor to can hope to
continue doing that for the next five
years but I would say ladies and
gentlemen having watched television this
evening it is a very good very good
result not only for myself here in
Watford but for David Cameron and I look
forward thank you I look forward to all
of the benefits that the last government
has brought to the Watford area to be
continued and I'll do my absolute best
to make sure that Watford continues to
thrive and prosper under a Conservative
government thank you very much indeed